hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the try not to laugh
challenge we're going right into it you
don't have time to race it's happening
now it's the most wonderful time for Sam
it just doesn't add up
[Music]
[Applause]
the pork am on the board people in the
gamble I don't know what to be more
concerned about
[Music]
oh that's horrible as horrible as
horrible as a horrible that's horrible
horrible no and this is where I die this
is where I die everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh what happens when a squirrel eats too
many fermented crab apples herbs ensure
what does happen to a squirrel that eats
too many fermented crab apples that's a
beautiful animal beautiful animal
beautiful animal nature is beautiful and
graceful he can climb that tree he's
climbing that tree
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
would you like for Christmas I don't
like this no come on now stand if you
can doesn t seem oh I've seen it I think
you know sang shil I think that it very
clip is maybe laugh in a previous try
not to laugh but anyway that is all that
and I already lost God holding the dogs
up to your face that just made me
laughing I didn't freaking care so that
is for the lightning round of the try
not to laugh challenge Christmas edition
hope you guys enjoyed it thank you
everybody so much for watching did you
laugh did you not laugh let me know down
in the comments below if you enjoyed
this check out the other try not to
laugh challenge as the other try not to
smile challenges and if you want you can
subscribe for more videos there coming
all the time so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye